hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to xep containment so I
people have regained my composure a
little bit since the last showed which
was a little bit scary for me and I
believe that yes I'm in the clear I've
got no LCPs on my tail for the first
time in ages so we're going to try could
we get through here hmm alrighty then
yeah we can okay oh no we can't oh
that's right
just wanted to closed off once it's
locked with the code that even if I did
that I don't think it would be anywhere
so stand back
repent back I know I hear the sounds of
Billy everywhere I know that these next
two are going to be absolutely nothing
we'll hopefully I can find a safe point
yeah so I can
uh-huh because I didn't save after I got
that basement in last episode and I'm
not touching that thing for all my life
not again oh man complete game please
this floor is poor d-class probably a
murder or a personnel which is like if
you ever thought about it that's it your
character is someone who is sentenced to
a life sentence and then brought into
the program for experimentation cruel
and unusual punishment indeed not going
in that elevator so this is the way
through and it's gotta be somewhere in
the heavy containment zone it just has
to be I just have to be thorough about
it which means that I'm going to be
doing a clean sweep while I got a lot of
demons
so you're slowly and surely we don't
have radical Larry on our tail this time
so I think we got a little more time
that we have in the past and this is
actually so what happens if I take the
left route and go all the way around
even though I know [ __ ] bill Billy
Bill Belichick is somewhere over here no
I'm not going to ping pong back goddamn
beligum yet Billy oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah okay oh so I don't have a direct
plan with which to do all this but I've
got a pretty decent idea of what I need
to do and if I find one of the Tesla
gates which I think was blocking up my
pattern before I might be able to fire
my way through it this time around just
got to keep pressing forward
oh good yeah okay yeah this was a Tesla
gate that I think oh god that scared the
piss out of me because that's the UH
that's the suit that I left behind my
[ __ ] left it standing there because
it was like it yeah whatever I won't
need that there so I think I can drop
this key card because I don't need it
you just put that on you just generally
put it on
whoa [ __ ] hi why oh okay so I think yeah
this was the UH
this is one of the earliest at CPS and
it's some sort of like virus that's real
bad look I knew this suit was going to
scare me [ __ ] but there's a way to get
in here pretty sure I need to like this
oh yeah oh [ __ ] oh okay it's fine it's
cycled like so something in here is a
reason there's a reason for this
there's something in there uh-huh I
don't have much to give up I'll drop it
for now but I don't like it how are you
in there the door was locked
[Music]
okay I guess all right we'll make my way
back so no I don't see a billy anywhere
I don't know how Billy could get in here
walk and Cloquet hi oh I don't like that
at all okay so whatever it's fine
because this is that it is okay whatever
it is it's okay I'm just gonna drop this
preemptively blink before I go grab it
and then I'm out I'm out I'm outie I'm
[ __ ] out II oh [ __ ] hi
y-yeah okay I closed it I closed it ah
okay somehow some way oh really good
[ __ ] you Billy Billy [ __ ] you Billy
Billy [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
okay get me in hell
okay now I can get in here oh [ __ ] me
[ __ ] me let me say please let me say Oh
unknown client please state your
identity and reason into the denial and
case expenses go through evacuating 0:08
security room incineration and
irradiation systems not functional
apparently disabled by an unknown klein
do not enter a chamber before it has
been concerned confirmed safe well too
late for me now comes complete this ride
here ah that's comforting okay so what
is the deal with this okay extreme
biological hazards in all related
protocols apply incineration and
irradiation measures will be deployed in
the event of political and military
actions complex prion samples of which
are stored in the g2 sites traits of the
0:08 prion include 100% infection is
100% lethality transmission through
exposed mucous membranes and all bodily
fluids flu-like symptoms 20 hours after
fern system dementia coma onset will be
considered onset of death red blood
cells greatly increased storage capacity
zones or blood flow nervous systems
unaffected total organ failure for
several hours metabolism subject will in
temp to ingest living humans o subject
can adapt to its damaged nervous system
but is limited to basic physical
activities including standing up
balancing on two legs walking biting
grabbing and crawling right subject will
attempt to ingest living humans if the
physical contact is made 500 scp-500 has
been found to completely cure SCP oo 8
even in the advanced stages of the
disease
[Music]
so that is that's the zombie virus is
what that is but why God why did I need
to come in - why are you so [ __ ]
terrifying okay so I didn't need to go
in here 173 is apparently not here so I
guess I'm fine then I'm gonna go grab my
my med kit again just in case I don't
like those sounds oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay now time for more of a clean sweep
with our belly on my neck oh oh oh was
it zooming here I don't think he's in
here anymore
no he's not he's not in here which means
that I can actually be thorough about
this and look where I'm going maybe
there was door control maybe you don't
store control in here maybe
no no no that was me
okay that wasn't it definitely wasn't it
it's okay though
just frankly that's good that means that
was an idiot last time Oh what now oh
come on oh no oh boy oh [ __ ] I'm dead no
you guys you don't understand I'm
already dead like it doesn't matter what
I do now right
[Music]
oh my god oh my god
oh okay now we're back alive which is
great I guess
[ __ ] hell okay so word to the wise
they magnate they've made that even more
terrifying than they have in the past
and I don't I don't like that at all
I forgot to get my med kit that's okay
I'm just gonna keep my head down you
know just in case like any of this but
you know that's the oh [ __ ] oh yeah
that's that's that's what that's fun
that's fun that's fun would that's about
it oh oh hey this guy again good Oh
Claude my friend ah self around my fun
friends friends with fun fun talk I
don't know if I was ever able to get in
there because I think they would be
closed off everything right you did that
thing I still got a deal with Oh nine
six oh boy okay here we go again looking
at the ground looking at the ground
looking at the really interesting ground
walking backwards oh my god oh my god is
our box
hi oh my god oh okay he's behind me
behind me oh my god entrance zone Oh
what whoa where am i oh oh is this where
I find that CP for 20 G yep it show hey
you moved you moved I saw that you moved
okay doing B's ah
that's incorrect [ __ ] oh hell yeah okay
there we go now why is why is everything
moving here in this room little little
weird oh boy
is that
radio transceiver I think it's out of
batteries I don't have any batteries
left to grab this computers unpowered
now which I remember before it wasn't
God I can't even save on anything and
just had to get myself that restriction
okay
but anyway huh I'm gonna end this
episode here [ __ ]
blocking god damn it okay alright I'm an
except so dear Mall last time I got to
move on ovary I can get back to this
soon so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know how I'm doing in
the comments down below and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]